this is real wasabi oh it's like thick
whoa
i don't know oh
it's really fun to see julie
oh but it's good
[Music]
and these are wasabi flavored holy shits
are hot
welcome to flavor binge
if you're just here for the binge you
can skip to the next chapter but stick
around to find out what wasabi actually
is
doesn't does not spell spicy at all yeah
has a bit of like a carrot vibe to it
smells nice smells like the stuff you're
used to seeing with your sushi but maybe
a little bit sweeter
raw wasab
i'm definitely tasting it
but
that's not how you make wasabi guys
without a grater you can't break the
cells down properly and therefore you're
not releasing all the chemicals to get
all the flavor out of it wasabi stores
two molecules in two separate
compartments which mix when the plant is
broken down to activate them kind of
like snapping a glow stick i don't know
if i can get like a paste off of this
but i'll try
yeah
whoa
like it's like significantly harder
[Music]
but there's a problem most of the
products you buy advertised as wasabi
flavor actually contain little or even
no wasabi some experts have even
estimated that 99 of the wasabi eaten by
americans is actually fake there's two
main reasons for that one of them you'll
have to wait 30 minutes for
but the other will tell you now
real wasabi is very expensive a kilogram
of fresh wasabi can cost up to 250 bucks
this little piece right here is
52
grams what did
so how much is that
this is mostly due to how hard it is to
grow wasabi is a super needy plant it
can be killed by the slightest change in
temperature or sunlight same so what the
food produces to instead well they tend
to use horseradish it's a plant from the
same family as wasabi with plenty of
alum isothiocyanate
i've never seen one in person before
and it looks kind of like a really thick
wizard's wand
i'm not going to say the other thing it
looks like on camera horseradish is way
cheaper than wasabi this 200 gram piece
cost me 1 pound 85 or about 2 and 45
cents the same amount of wasabi would
cost you 50
this is like the smallest piece they had
look at this look how big
uh this thing a horseradish is
it's like a
leg of a baby grand piano let's put it
to the test ourselves and make our own
fake wasabi
it does smell pretty similar to the
wasabi dip when i chop that
oh i felt that
do we have a hammer
oh there we go
it's hard to get a firm grasp on
stop it
all right rest of this goes right in the
trash
i'm gonna add a little bit of mustard
do you guys too much
what do you think
a little too green
so here is my homemade fake wasabi
and it does kind of smell like wasabi
it's exactly oh ooh i could fill up my
my nostrils that's exactly what i would
expect
in both the us and the uk you can get a
range of wasabi powders and wasabi
pastes but with varying amounts of
actual wasabi in them don't know what
we're going to do with a kilogram of 2
wasabi powder after this shoot but
the only 100 pure wasabi powder i could
find in the uk was from a website called
just ingredients but it cost 844 pounds
per kilogram so we've decided not to buy
that one this gigantic bag seems to have
zero real wasabi and only has
horseradish and mustard listed on the
label as flavors ugh
woof it doesn't smell like wasabi
yeah already a much different a much
more pleasant odor
and just look at the pot you can totally
like visually tell the difference right
the handy oh yeah
this whoa this smells pretty nice
that's got the strongest taste of
anything i've had so far
yeah
whoa
whoa
100 percent
about a spice it was like a lot earthier
go ahead look at how happy this guys
look at this guy
he's just thrilled he's thrilled to be
here we all are
we'll start with this one from s b which
contains just 4.5 real wasabi
enough wasabi
so this is the real estate oh it's like
thick look at that look how thick this
is
whoa
it's really fun to see julie
oh but it's good
that's actually really good
and we got this one from yutaka which
contains five percent real wasabi
i learned nothing
utaka's premium version which contains
65 percent wasabi which is pretty good
i can definitely taste the difference i
can definitely i can't believe i'm
saying this but i can taste the
difference and this one is way better
but i do like them both boy this is
really good i'm surprised by how much
i'm liking this
sweet let's try some wasabi crisps i've
actually got really high hopes for these
i feel like wasabi and beef would be a
good combination we put a lot of like
horseradish sauce on our beef in the uk
so this seems pretty good
oh that smells good it's not beefy
[Music]
the first thing i get is wasabi but then
it kind of dissipates pretty quickly and
then you get this kind of like beef
there's some sweetness to it i don't
know what's causing that
no
wait
i hate them but not gonna like them
next up we got these demon slayer mini
snacks which i think are like little
crisps kind of stacked in a tube i don't
know what demon slayer is judging by the
guy up here is
anime oh look how little these guys are
know
probably
an
look at those
it's kind of like tiny pringles
like mini pringles
weaker wasabi flavor
quite a lot of wasabi from that this
looks like
dried pasta
see that
you know i would have said
sweet and wasabi don't go together but
they actually kind of do
so i think these are very out of date i
think they may have gone off in march
these are doritos wasabi risk 5.0 which
i think is from turkey
they don't really smell of wasabi
and they're just going to look like a
standard nacho cheese type dorito
yeah that was just a cheesy burrito
that's anti-climactic turns out once
we've translated the bag that only a
couple of the ones in here are actually
wasabi flavoured and are very spicy so
i'm gonna have to basically keep eating
until i hit one
[Music]
yeah
that tasted like they've tried to put
wasabi on it maybe before they went off
i definitely have got some wasabi
flavour from this bag at some point i
just can't tell exactly where it's come
from which is a bit disappointing oh
these look like cheetos
uh-oh
whoa
these are super spicy oh wow
but i kind of love them yeah dude
[Music]
once you get used to the wasabi flavor
look it's kind of awesome
oh it's tingling
[Music]
that was underwhelming uh next up is
this koikea wasabi nori potato chips
which actually sound really good
great color on these look at this
that's green boy a subtle combination of
soft and sharp wasabi with a touch of
sophisticated mild nori
these are really good
you get wasabi but i think they're right
it's quite a soft wasabi
i don't even know what this i don't even
know it i mean i'm assuming this is a
this is a wasabi guy
right so these are korean wasabi snacks
[Music]
take it back but he's actually really
good dude like we have crab chips
and we have shrimp chips if i can recall
i've never had fish flavored chips
this might be the worst thing i've ever
tasted
as well crabs
look at these guys
if i got this regularly i would no
problem eat this whole bag
wouldn't even wasabi wouldn't even slow
me down
shrimp versus shrimp
my ears are starting to ring
i think my body is starting to fight
back in my stomach oh these little puffs
i don't even taste wasabi
you i've been looking forward to these
i've been looking forward to these these
look like they're popular
i like the shrimp chips taste the shrimp
[Music]
looks like i mean
i'm not tasting any wasabi these are
very little
puffy
puffy crisp they're little puffy things
look at that
my only question would be why would you
serve that in a can if it's not a
pringle
look at that it's a little cheeto thing
here we go
i mostly get sweetness from those
i don't know exactly where that's coming
from
there is definitely some wasabi but also
again like not particularly hot out of
all these as far as wasabi balance i
like these
these were good and what was the one
that i insisted you guys have this
all three of these great balance
with the wasabi they added it in
perfectly
it's pretty good
crackers and seaweed
uh tempura crisps country and savory
seaweed oh yes let's see what that is
see
no
nope
no first up we've got these itsy crispy
seaweed thins itsu is like a chain in
the uk that does asian food
that's pretty good
wasabi oh i know how unfun this is
ah
it's a seaweed part that i hate to be
harnessed next up we've got these
ocean's halo seaweed thins i mean they
look identical to the previous ones
these are very salty but i get almost no
wasabi especially compared to at sea
ones why are we doing this
is this
why are we eating seaweed
i don't know
nope as bad as the other ones then
finally we've got some marks and spencer
seaweed thins
i think these are the most wasabi of the
ones that i've tried
probably second place to those
last place to those
korean seaweed snack wasabi
all the seaweed was trash
there was some crackers it's another
itsu offering these ones are prawn
crackers with mild wasabi
i get a very small amount of wasabi
honestly i don't think it's like a
worthwhile addition to a prawn cracker i
think they're already tasty enough as
they are
the first thing i tasted was wasabi but
that did disappear pretty quickly and
then it's just kind of nice sweet rice
cracker not bad
give me something fine get this get this
horrible seaweed taste out of my mouth
oh
ah
i
think
you don't get to choose how much goes on
these oh girls i think we get to choose
i don't know i don't want them don't
like this
that's far too much are you insane
i feel like there's a revenge for how
difficult i am to work with
i hate
i hate everything about this first up
fat-free wasabi dijon
[Music]
dressing yes this cracker has been
marinating
in the sauce
[Music]
nope
well i can barely taste
the wasabi
oh there it is
it's obviously got the texture of mayo
and the kind of creaminess but then does
still have a fairly strong wasabi taste
coming through
not two things your brain kind of
expects to be associated with each other
for real
this much
that's just like more mayo than i want
to put in my mouth at one time
what's that be mustard
it's got that
oh
no oh i don't like that
even mounted wasabi ranch
i'm getting very little wasabi from
these
i wonder why that is now the texture of
this is bizarre it's got all these weird
lumps in it like what is i don't want
that from a sauce
not point three percent wasabi so i'm
assuming it's not gonna be
not spicy
it's just unpleasant
chunky sauce that tastes very salty
a versatile condiment with that i love
this
velvety zing
all right
oh wow
it was velvety
and it did have a zing
hey kikkoman copywriters
you're doing it guys
and then last but by no means least we
have this one the wasabio hot sauce
[Music]
ass kicking wasabi hot sauce
look at that donkey that is an ass that
is kicking
it also says habanero on here
wish i knew that before you dumped half
the bottle in the chip
oh man
oh crap
ah man
but i like it
this goes in the joe spicy hall of fame
whoa
this is a maybe i'm not gonna yeah
these were kind of all bad i don't think
i would eat any of these out of choice
in the future
i'd say
the wasabi mayo and the hot sauce were
maybe like a two out of five and these
ones were both like a one out of five
how do i look i look like i'm i feel
like i'm like losing a fight
peas and nuts
peas and nuts
gonna try a bunch of pizza
let's do a lightning round style ranking
of all of these by spice
five out of ten one out of ten
six out of ten
what's that we're right dinos with the
lightning what's that what was that word
read that loud for me
hell no let me get a zero
two out of ten wasabi edamame
zero what is happening here
seven out of ten stuffy almonds
point five
five out of ten wasabi
coated peanuts
i'll give those guys an eight two laptop
four out of ten
five out of ten
three out of ten
i'll give that a one
i think i could easily handle ten wasabi
pizza ones ten's nothing
i'll do 20.
come on come on
if i put 15 to 20 of these in my mouth
at once
that ups the scale to like a four
three going out
a handful
[Applause]
oh oh sh
stockholm half guard
i almost peed myself a little was there
something
oh man
now we're heading into some of the more
weird and wonderful wasabi flavoured
snacks out there and boy do we have some
surprising combinations i'll start with
the banger which is wasabi cheese
it smells
quite quite heavily of wasabi it's
extremely rubbery like super plasticky
and has that very quite threatening
green wax on the outside
yeah that's um
it's not not for me i don't think it's
just like i say got the texture of quite
a rubbery
cheese
with a fairly strong wasabi aftertaste
not really spicy
just that kind of like earthiness that
you would maybe get from actual wasabi i
too also ordered the wasabi cheese it
has not arrived i received an email a
couple days ago telling me that's not
going to get here until february but
what i did get is this
vegan
jerky
wasabi flavored
i don't want this at all
meatless jerky we did it
[Music]
it doesn't smell good
it smells i know you can hear me because
you have headphones on
this smells real bad oh god i hate this
meatless vegan jerky
is terrible
uh and no wasabi flavor in that at all
next up we have this one it's mike
popcorn and it's wasabi soy sauce
flavored
[Applause]
greasy from the cheese
[Music]
that's actually quite pleasant that's
pretty nice
calling this the mystery bag i saw harry
also had it so i don't know what i
bought and what this is
local translator yuli song is saying
that this
is fire flavored
let's find out together i don't know
what this is
uh-huh
yep
oh man
yeah it's hot that goes in the hall of
fame
now these ones with this very alarming
packaging with the big warning label our
frito-lay forbidden wasabi spicy snacks
these do kind of look like cheetos they
also kind of look like knickknacks which
are a specific british brand of crisps
let's give it a try
okay
yeah well
i can see why these are forbidden that's
pretty strong
[Music]
yeah those are good those are actually
spicy we're doing what's we're moving
into the wasabi and sweets wasabi and
chocolate zone with first this just says
jackie's chocolates jackie if you're
watching thank you for your chocolates
jack i've been eating wasabi all day so
maybe that's it but
next to no wasabi
but what have i learned from before
if you can't taste wasabi just shove a
bunch more in your mouth
now with slightly less alarming
packaging but also supposedly very spicy
are these raging fire wasabi crackers
that seems like a waste of packaging
lots of plastic here
wow okay
we might have a win up
we might have a 10.
[Laughter]
those are powerful wow
hells to the yeah wasabi kitkats
i'm intrigued to see how wasabi meshes
with chocolate so let's give it a go
hey good job
i mean
it's delicious
i can't quite explain why
this might be the best tasting thing
and of course we have this wasabi
shampoo
if you watch food wars you thought in
this episode man joe's hair is looking a
little bit nicer
scalp's looking a little bit healthier a
little more bounce to that guy what's
going on your eyes do not deceive you
i've spent at least the last week this
long using wasabi shampoo and this very
head of hair and i gotta say it's pretty
nice
it doesn't really smell wasabi like but
yeah i honestly have no idea how to
incorporate this into the video but
there was a film called wasabi starring
jorano
and i just thought it was worth it
yeah i got it too wasabi the movie
i don't know anything about it
i haven't seen it
i don't know what else to say
that's 30 minutes up
that means it's time to talk about the
second reason as to why all your wasabi
is fake
so yeah in just 30 minutes our wasabi
has gone from that lovely vibrant green
paste to this it's kind of a slightly
sad looking yellow and brown
crusty little blob
and it has
almost no odor
that's really weird
no
nothing
that's wild
there's so little little flavour to that
wow
wow it's flavorless
like it's it's not even like kind of
wasabi-ish completely flavorless wow
there are a couple of ways around this
volatility like how some of the powders
from earlier were freeze-dried to
preserve the flavor but if you're at a
restaurant unless you're seeing a
rhizome being grated right in front of
you you're probably eating fake wasabi
i am sick of wasabi are we done yet
not yet joe we've got one more surprise
up our sleeves for you
yeah
oh okay back in a second
[Applause]
[Music]
is that too much
i'm back the crew has set this up i know
very little about what is in any of
these i'm assuming some kind of wasabi
based surprises in one of them but we're
going to find out i'm going to pick one
and eat it wish me luck
oh food
all right
oh
oh my god it's so bad
oh my god
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
check out our fast food chemistry
episode where i made popcorn chicken
using 42 ingredients